mansion has strange beauty to it maybe
I'll find a way to end this without
killing here engine dosh
you would build something like this
and why
ah someone's activated one of the
mechanisms in my house janutian my home
is always open it's one of my great
curiosity seen how the common I'm to
navigate the shifting news I'm carrying
gin dosh but you must know that before
you stands an invention that will endure
beyond my time the gene dash clock works
soldier marvel at the clockwork
soldier's heart the metallic skeleton
and razor-sharp blades teacher has whale
oil tanks are spread across the frame
and heat behind protective am both
panels visual awareness in the front and
back on attire detection in case the
head unit sustains catastrophic damage
my greatest creation I invite you to
continue stranger just come upstairs
meet with me face to face the upper hall
that did go out there come into the
gallery so I
your syrup there you are magnificent
now that I see you I worked out who you
are not a hired cutthroat your clothes
are too fine an aristocratic thrill
seeker that's closer do you train with
weapons formally which another salon
fences good back alley all that and you
have your father's eyes your Imperial
Majesty welcome Lady Emily called with
impressive gin dash then you must also
know why I'm here I'd assume my
involvement with the Duke brought you to
my door or mail your ass who washed up
anton sokolov comfortably residing near
central chamber either way company until
whatever it is music but if you fall
I'll have no part in caring to my lab
for dissection and study until I then
come to pass are you today to me I'll
see you soon Jin dosh I'm hill there
clockwork soldiers that an Intel over in
my home okay trigger exploration grid
unauthorized presence playback for
combat protocol in part I made this
place of luxury and spectacle I suppose
but it's more than that this place is a
testament to engineering itself
you'll meet one of my clockwork soldiers
I'll have questions about that what I
have you restrained anyways the
clockwork it'll wake up on its own 15
doubt they're blind but they can still
hear
ah the space behind the walls
so this is how it works ah I know where
you are
Fred hey according to the scale bar and
my receptors quite quickly aristocratic
profile and its back after your last the
left behold is a work of defeating
industry the very pinnacle of adventure
oh and the element damn you what's going
on here
be careful this was devised to test the
limits of the clockwork soldiers quite
dangerous if you're really looking for
Sokoloff that old nag is around here
somewhere
triggering electrostatic discharge work
you've just destroyed served as the
prototype for 10 perception how I didn't
add it to my gallery
Sokolov
and it B is that young Emily called when
Anton save your strength I came to take
you out of here gender has bigger plans
than you know an army of his clockwork
soldiers would be the end I'm going to
visit gin dash to old friend
so you've taken so how much you'll be
safer in the cameras of love then I know
Jin daschle visit
astonishing you free them on so long
ah
I thought I that one right here let's
check the place bus
I wonder who's back
in founders of your hurt no royal
protector around this time dear Emily
playback indicate some detection without
certainty
did you learn it destroying my
masterpieces each one costs a fortune in
prison timing the pleasure of things set
into motion from the bright-red birth of
the cosmos to your last
I won't let you take you so called was
the great thinker of his time and now he
belongs to me another clockwork down
eternal costs princely sum my issue
sokoloff is now safe and sound and yet
here you are again back the machine has
detected something
hello are you there I can't sense your
weight of applause or the sounds of your
breathing any other reasonable guess
that somehow you got the onion a walls
of the house you've managed to
deactivate my wall of light
you're quite close now I can't remember
any other visitor getting so far if your
pride anticipation
that's it closer and closer I'm waiting
Everlast Imperial Majesty how will you
be do you realize you're only the second
person to set foot in this rule the most
sophisticated laboratory in the aisles
please kind of damage anything
generating machine mr. tik-tok work
soldier dispatch this intruder bill
idling that this boy gets the world on
the waist cavity
kiran jen dosh
machine is experiencing uncertainty
everything
should begin stones affinity combat
protocol eight playback in the Asian
young woman arm playback for my
protocols this blaze have some eludes
the machine
detached 30 but protection okay shut it
down
what is this thing anton sokolov once
the Royal physician and head of the
academy of natural philosophy in your
prime the most sought-after painter in
all the Empire my hero and younger days
now my puppet if you're going to use
this in elegant looking device against
me get on with engine dosh I'm not sure
when you hope to a cup of nations are
draining away too much electricity is
the function of the apparatus patient's
friend patience the sequence of events
is important you'll come to understand
my electroshock machine but win before
or after that lightly sure I'd
when it did appears will tell me that
everyone you will love the sound of his
own voice perhaps device patella said no
sadly it cannot but what it can do is
take from you the thing you love the
Lord your precious intellect if you
won't agree to collaborate on the
clockwork prototype I'll use the device
on that brain of yours some law I'd
appear drooling idiot at least they will
be bothered by any more of your friendly
what cool t is this with this machine
maybe you won't have to die after all
gin dosh
the electroshock machine should work now
you don't know what you're doing
anything
dude do this so much will be lost an age
of offenses
barely had to come to this chill dash
please kill me please make me die
you can't have put me
you